pero 24 es tiempo de hablar de economía
y estamos para eso con nuestra
periodista daniela blandón que nos va a
contar lo más importante en esta materia
ni la bienvenida empezamos hablando de
ecuador este país que tiene acciones
presidenciales el 7 de febrero como
recibirá el nuevo presidente la economía
del país daniela ahora liliana mire el
ganador de los comicios del próximo
domingo en este país va a heredar una
economía que ya venía en crisis antes de
la pandemia la nación de poco más de 17
millones de personas comenzó a
experimentar una desaceleración
económica y fiscal desde que empezaron a
caer los precios del petróleo en 2015
pero ya agravada por la pandemia se
estima que la economía llegó a decrecer
hasta un 9% el año pasado la cifra más
reciente de desempleo era de 6,6 por
ciento cuando se estaba apenas
recuperando del cierre que paralizó el
70 por ciento de las empresas y que dejó
a 600 mil desempleados también tiene una
pobreza de alrededor del 35 por ciento
pero la economía ecuatoriana liliana en
los últimos años también se ha afectado
por las dolorosas medidas de ajuste
las necesarias para equilibrar las
cuentas gubernamentales hoy tiene una
deuda de 160 mil millones de dólares que
equivalen al 60 por ciento de su
producto interno bruto y está en una
especie de hipoteca con el fondo
monetario internacional porque porque el
próximo año le debe empezar a pagar lo
que le debe
bueno a daniela pero eeuu en cambio
registró la tasa de desempleo más baja
desde marzo de 2020 son noticias
agridulces porque por un lado el
desempleo se ubicó en el 63 % y si es
verdad que es el más bajo desde marzo de
2020 en abril se había disparado hasta
el 14 7 por ciento después de estar en
un mínimo histórico del 35 desde
entonces se ha venido reduciendo sin
embargo la generación de empleo es la
que está estancada en el primer mes del
año se crearon apenas 49 mil plazas
laborales en un país que recordemos
perdió más de 32 millones de puestos
durante la pandemia de este total se
estima que solamente se ha recuperado un
poco más de la mitad
daniela y vamos a hablar de la
multinacional suiza glencore que dejará
de producir carbón
bueno su filial colombiana prodeco es el
tercer productor de carbón en dos minas
ubicadas en el norte del país que lleva
operando por más de 30 años en diciembre
de esta empresa le había pedido a las
autoridades colombianas que suspendieran
sus títulos mineros por cuatro años
debido a que los altos costos del
combustible encarece en la producción y
los precios del carbón están muy bajos
pero el gobierno no aceptó como
respuesta la compañía explicó que revisó
sus operaciones y llegó a la conclusión
de que el reinicio de éstas no les
resulta económicamente viable aunque no
se va a ir del todo a seguir operando un
puerto que tiene muy cerca de su
operación ya que presta un servicio
público pero la mayoría de sus más de
1200 empleados está en las minas y ahora
incertidumbre porque vendrá a liliana el
proceso de determinar qué va a pasar con
estos yacimientos y estas regiones en
las que están ubicados pues llevan
décadas viviendo prácticamente de la
operación carbonífera bien sea de manera
directa o por a través de los servicios
que presta a esta industria
daniela y corea del sur construirá la
planta de energía eólica más grande
dio a conocer este viernes un ambicioso
plan de 43 mil 200 millones de dólares
para construir de aquí a 2030 una planta
de energía eólica esto como parte de los
esfuerzos por supuesto para reducir la
dependencia de combustibles fósiles la
cuarta economía más grande de asia
quiere eliminar las emisiones de dióxido
de carbono en 2050 y este es considerado
un primer paso hasta el momento el
parque eólico más grande del mundo es el
jónsi ubicado en gran bretaña y este
aspira a ser ocho veces más grande
daniela los indicadores de la jornada o
street del cerro su mejor semana desde
noviembre con nuevos máximos históricos
en sus índices nasdaq y standard and
poor's así se recupera de varios días
impactados por el fenómeno gamestop las
bolsas europeas se cerraron con
resultados dispares tras el descenso del
desempleo en eeuu y en américa latina
los mercados cerraron mixtos sin muchos
cambios a nivel la ciudad al día pues
mire entre 300 millones y 500 millones
de dólares en promedio generan en
ingresos las regiones anfitrionas del
super bowl esto habitualmente no
este año se estima que no llegarían ni a
la mitad por las restricciones del 19
según un informe del instituto de
pronósticos económicos de la universidad
de florida central
recordemos allí es donde se va a
celebrar este juego de asia daniela por
la información de economía ellos te
dirán es por estar en las 24 continúen
con más aquí siempre al 24 y en 324
puntocom
[Música]